pas
là
ils ne sont pas sots c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire ils sont forts connus
est talentueux
ils ont réussi leur vie dialoguer souza
figuier à propos des hommes et des
femmes en tirait la matière d'un livre
publié chez orban pourquoi pas les
changes commence fort mal cependant aux
banalités convenu à propos de la
libération d une et de l'inconstance des
autres succèdent d'indigents
considération bab le plus digne du
boudoir que du salon tout change quand
les auteurs en viennent à parler d'eux
mêmes
vraiment et de la littérature lévy a
raison je crois d'avouer son émotion
devant le spectacle du quotidien d'une
femme ce que giroud appel l'intimité
obscures
elle n'a pas tort me semble-t-il
d'avouer son désarroi devant la laideur
physique je peux faire l'amitié avec un
homme disgracié dit elle pas l'amour ils
divergent à propos d'albert cohen que
lévis égal à proust et que giroud
reconnaît avoir toujours trouvé assez
barbant y compris dans belle du seigneur
c'est un vrai plaisir que de lire sous
la plume de lévis un hommage pour
justifier à paul bourget qui sut
soutenir gide et proust une explication
de la faveur incompréhensible dont jouit
pierre drieu la rochelle sans doute du
fait de sa réputation d'homme à femmes
et enfin un éloge de sophie volland lamy
est la correspondante de diderot sept
femmes de notre temps